eq olivier goujon journaliste écrivain
et c'est nice qui se trouve actuellement
à milan en plein confinement bonsoir
olivier goujon merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france tout d'abord
première question comment tu es comment
allez vous comment vous vivez ce
confinement à milan bonsoir merci merci
ca va écouter ça va bien comme comment
le vit on sort pas on peut pas en fait
c'est une précision sur ce qui a été dit
tout à l'heure on peut sortir
il s'agit de sortir avec une ce qu'on
appelle une auto certification c'est à
dire que on certifie on promet quand
sort pour un bon motif
donc on peut sortir pour faire des
courses mais l'essentiel parce que de
toute façon les magasins sont fermés
on peut sortir pour raisons de santé
c'est à dire se rendre à des
consultations par exemple ou pour des
raisons urgentes
on peut également s'y pour une bonne
raison encore une fois voyager voilà
donc on peut sortir qu'il existe des
amendes on a mis en place un système
d'avant pour des gens qui transgresse
les nouvelles normes pour de mauvaises
raisons
on a beaucoup diminué la possibilité des
mauvaises raisons puisque toute façon
tous les bars les discothèques les
restaurants tout est fermé les magasins
un peu plus en plus faire de shopping
donc ya pas vraiment non plus une raison
de sortir en sorte pour l'essentiel pour
les choses qu'on peut pas éviter parce
que je n'en ai plus on ne peut plus
faire du shopping
est-ce qu'on peut tout de même aller
dans les pharmacies et dans les
supermarchés j'imagine comment ça se
passe c'est ce que on n'en est pas au
rationnement chine ont fait la queue
pour faire les courses par exemple alors
les pharmacies s'est ouvert certaines
pharmacies ont mis en place un système
de guichet avec des files d'attentes
les supermarchés sont ouverts également
de manière un petit peu fractionné ont
fait la queue dehors en respectant un
distance d'un mètre ou d'un mètre
cinquante
et puis à l'intérieur d'un voilà on fait
rentrer les gens 5 par 5 10 par 10 20
par ben ça dépend de la taille d'un des
magasins voilà il n'y a pas de
rationnement les magasins sont
approvisionnés
ça marche pas très bien en revanche le
système de livraison à domicile puisque
évidemment il ya énormément d'attentes
tout le monde le demande et donc ça ça
fonctionne pas mais on trouve de tout
dans les magasins comment réagit la
population est ce qu'elle est inquiète
est ce que finalement il ya beaucoup de
résilience beaucoup de calme de la part
des italiens alors j'entendais tout à
l'heure le président macron je trouve
que en italie justement on a en fait
nation c'est à dire que il ya eu par
exemple dimanche dernier quand il ya eu
le
les premières rumeurs de confinement à
milan il ya eu des mouvements de panique
les trains ont été pris d'assaut les
gens essayaient de s'échapper vers le
sud sur tout ce qui avait de la famille
dans le sud de l'italie qui est beaucoup
moins touchés vous le savez est donc on
a eu quelques mouvements panique
également début mars quand on a quand on
a vu les premiers confinement arrivé à
acodo n'ya pas biya là on a eu des des
scènes un petit peu dramatique également
dans les supermarchés qui étaient pris
d'assaut
mais globalement globalement l'italie
réagit très bien les gens sont
solidaires ils sont responsables et ils
assument globalement un comportement
très digne on entend parfois des choses
peut-être inquiétante notamment sur
l'état des hôpitaux en italie alors
rumeur info ou intox notamment voilà pas
de place dans les morts on est obligés
d'évacuer les corps pour les enterrer
ailleurs est ce que tout ça c'est de
l'intox ou c'est la véritable situation
en italie n'ont cessé la véritable
situation c'est à dire que globalement
si vous voulez le la france et l'italie
choisisse de réagir de manière
diamétralement opposées à la crise pour
à peu près les mêmes raisons qui les
raisons en beauce et des raisons
politiques économiques et sociales il
s'agit notamment de deux de masquer des
politiques de santé qui ont été conçus
suivi la même voie depuis 30 ans et puis
qu'on menait les pays la france l'italie
où il
ils en sont aujourd'hui c'est à dire
avec un hôpital public ardemment sa cage
et on peut le dire comme ça alors en
italie oui aujourd'hui il ya des
carences dans les hôpitaux le personnel
est très très mobilisé
on fait travailler on fait revenir des
médecins ont fait travailler des
étudiants enfin voilà tout le monde est
sur le pont pour le dire de manière un
peu triviale malgré tout évidemment on
voit bien qu'avec 5 ou 6000 personnes
hospitalisées d'un coup le système de
santé atteint ses limites
on a vu en a vu des cas dramatiques on a
vu des infirmières dire qu'elle devait
faire des choix pour des listes
d'attentes à 1
enfin l'ue devait mettre en place des
listes d'attentes pour l'accès à des
appareils respiratoires par exemple
c'est dramatique on est quand même en
train de parler de d'un des pays les
plus riches du monde les italiens
notamment les médecins italiens qu'on
est un petit peu ironisé sur l'attitude
française qui semblait minimiser les
dangers du coc vie de 19 pour vous avez
écouté visiblement emmanuel macron ce
soir est ce que il a pris la mesure en
fin de ce danger du coroner virus je
n'en suis pas convaincu du tout je pense
que écoutez c'est c'est assez simple
finalement les médecins nous disent que
les courbes de progression du virus sont
parallèles et se suivent entre la france
et l'italie et que la france
simplement quelques jours de retard sur
l'italie donc la france choisit de
réagir en faisant profil bas donc par
exemple on le voit très bien au niveau
des tests tampon qui sont effectués sur
la population en italie on a déjà
effectué près de 80 mille tests en
france on refuse de dire combien de test
on a effectué on sait cependant que
c'est beaucoup beaucoup moins
donc en fait en ne testant pas la
population si vous voulez naturellement
on va trouver moins de 2
on va trouver moins de cas positifs
c'est la même chose sur les doubles
pathologie en italie on comptabilise
dans la catégorie décès du cornât virus
énormément de doutes double pathologie
je rappelle que en lombardie par exemple
la moyenne d'âge des décès est de 81 ans
mais c'est peut-être des gens qu aurait
eu encore deux trois quatre cinq ans de
lee sang le corps d'un virus ils sont
comptabilisés dans les décès dûs
coronavirus en france s'ils sont pas
détectés ils sont naturellement pas
comptabilisés dans les décès dûs quand
la viole donc j'ai l'impression ce n'est
pas une impression de leurs certitudes
quand on fait profil bas sur la réaction
française
l'italie de son côté a peut-être
effectivement dramatiser la réaction
depuis le début mais finalement on
s'aperçoit d'ailleurs on a les premiers
résultats on s'aperçoit que à codognan
arabiya les confinements portent leurs
fruits
l'épidémie ne progresse plus à codognan
a pas bien on sait que les confinements
ont fonctionné en chine
et puis énormément le médecin français
nous disent aussi que à partir d'un
certain niveau de contamination c'est la
seule réponse mais free de réponse
efficace
merci beaucoup olivier goujon
journaliste scénariste écrivain confiné
actuellement à milan merci de ce point
complet